[Music]
hello how are you greetings cristian
casares one day after thousands of
supporters of the president give another they
demonstrated to me in washington they broke
into the capitol in protest
of the election results the fbi and
other federal agencies continue to
investigate and seek to identify
some of the protesters who
vandalized the legislative building
confirmed that four people died
including a woman who suffered
gunshot wounds this morning congress
certified joe biden as the president-
elect while the
social networks of the president of donald trump
have been stopped  and definitely by
facebook and in this great and his twitter account is
still blocked as much
as legislators from the state of nevada
called the events an attack on the
democracy of the country the
basketball player from a vision collins
appeared in court this morning where
accuses him of driving drunk and causing a
fatal accident young man is angry  rent to
charges of driving under the influence of
alcohol and reckless driving
resulting in death documents also
reveal that collins has a history
of traffic violations
the police report revealed that the young man was driving
at a speed of
over 85 miles per hour and under
drunk when he collided with the
car of 52-year-old erc
echevería near fort apache and blue demon
echevería streets died in the accident a
fire completely consumed a
condominium complex under
construction in the northwest valley
near sky point and  It was already shortly
after midnight on Thursday, the
flames and smoke became so
intense that they could be seen from
miles behind, although no one was injured,
at least 65 firefighters helped put out
the fire and due to the delicate state
of the structure, the investigation was not carried out.
has been completed, so the
cause of the accident is unknown, the damage is estimated
at almost half a million dollars  it is and i
paid close attention if you are looking for a
job resorts world is
recruiting for its grand opening this
coming summer the company claims that
over 75k people have already applied
and the virtual interviews have
gone very well the public is reminded
that  there are still a variety of
open positions visit news now
dotcom for more details mayor
carmen women
today her annual report on the state of
the city is expected to detail her
vision for the coming year and post-
pandemic the report will be virtual and you are
invited to  community members to
participate in the conversation by submitting
questions using the hashtag state a
vegas and it is anticipated that there will be heavy traffic
in the area near or around the new
chef ley fast food restaurant at
la cross team and fort apache and upon its
opening day  Today this is the tenth
location of the restaurant chain and
although its dining room will not be open for
now, customers will be able to pick up their  drive-
through or drive-
thru food and a former web gamer if he
takes his talents from the octagon to the
streets of las vegas
julie gomez is now a new officer with
the metropolitan police department
and is stationed at the
south station  centro del valle com is a
renowned and professional martial arts athlete
since 2007 now he has
a record of 9 fights won and 5
lost he is also the co-founder of the
cobra falls academy here in the valley
now a look at the weather conditions
in  our region for today
a cloudy day is expected with the
high temperature reaching 60 degrees
the cold will return during this
weekend when a drop in temperatures is expected
then you can change
your coat for something lighter for a
single moment when temperatures
rise  60 degrees and no sign
of rain for the next week I'm
Cristian Casares and this is your igloo
now report in Spanish
[Mús  ica]